would you ever do a Simpson Johnson
reality show no I haven't I honestly
like after doing a reality show I have
not been able to watch reality shows you
put it all out there there's always that
the happy times the sad times the light
the darkness you did not have to why did
you want to do this and what was the
hardest part to revisit I really wanted
to share my journey with everyone
because I wanted people to know the ups
and the downs and the struggles and the
things that we have to go back through
in our life and sort out to really
understand who we are in the present
moment and I just learned so many tools
through therapy after sobriety it was
just the next step for me in my life and
I am an open book and you always happen
which is why we love you it always has
been nobody should be shocked by I mean
maybe you'll be shocked by some of the
struggles that I was actually facing or
some of the stuff that I struggled with
as a child but I think that you know I I
just feel like right now I feel so
present and I'm just ready to share it
and let everybody else know that they
can get through it too I cried a number
of times when reading your story one of
them was when you were talking about the
sexual abuse that you experienced as a
child and it was also incredibly
heart-wrenching but when you talked
about protecting Ashley were four years
apart so I wanted to protect her even
though I hadn't talked to my parents yet
about it
I had my ways of making sure that none
of this was happening to her and yes I
allowed the abuse to continue without
saying anything so within revisiting
the sexual abuse I really wanted to go
back to that child that I was and the
feelings that I felt and you know a lot
of the stuff was shocking to my parents
and to my family to my Nana like
literally like everybody has been like
calling me like why didn't you tell us
why didn't you why didn't you tell us
you know and that's why I wanted to talk
about it because if my daughter were to
have ever been experiencing that I want
to know immediately it changes who you
are as a parent it does absolutely two
changes it absolutely has made me put
boundaries on a lot of things as a
parent and I wanted other moms to read
it and be aware that this stuff is
happening and your child you know it
could feel like they're trying to
protect you you know I was trying to
protect my family by not talking about
it because I didn't want it to burden
them I didn't want to break their hearts
but it was destroying you on buying me
on the inside and I didn't know until a
lot later in life how many issues that
it actually caused you know with with
going into bad relationships and going
into just wanting to fix everybody and
you know like the the girl that was
abusing me was abused as well and I felt
sorry for her and I didn't she wasn't
talking about it so I didn't want to
tell people that what she was going
through and so I just think there comes
a time in our lives where we have to
know that truth is what protects us and
says are you afraid of the truth
those changes can be made that's right
moment I think for a lot of us in
reading your book it is hard to believe
that the beautiful extremely talented
woman Jessica Simpson sitting before me
nearly died from substance abuse and
alcohol how did you keep that a secret
for so long I mean it wasn't a secret to
everybody around me it was definitely a
secret to the world
but it wasn't necessarily a secret like
when I got the call from the doctor
telling me that my liver levels were
super high and you know it was like my
35th birthday and we were all in st.
Barths you know it was like so I got the
call and I immediately told everybody so
it wasn't like I don't hold back anymore
but at the time I was just I was shocked
that I I took myself to that place where
I actually could just not be here
anymore and not be here for my children
in that moment I realized and I knew
that I needed to stop and I needed to
like cut back but it wasn't until later
that I actually took action and I think
so we're like really get to the place to
make a change you have to be very ready
and willing to do it because once I was
ready then the change was actually a lot
easier you know because I wanted I was
allocated the bottle like I was like
yeah it was like an X or something
that's like I got it like rid myself but
I love how honest you were about it you
were like I'm gonna be honest I had one
more glitter Cup and I said bring in the
interventionist that's great how did he
manage to build a billion-dollar fashion
empire with this going on behind the
scenes no matter what like I am always
in
our meetings and in our approvals even
if I was drinking I was still present
like I was still alert I was tucking
people in I was taking care of everybody
so that was just like my nurturing
mentality it's just it's just who I am I
I was able to function that way until it
got so out of control that I knew I just
needed to surrender but I mean I I
showed up for all the stuff and I
continued to help grow the business and
I was there for all of it
and I never missed a beat until I got
sober and then once I got sober I was
like I need me time I like and I'm not
like I always felt so self they're
saying that like I felt bad going on
vacation yeah so it was like no I need
to take this time off and clear my head
and like go back through the journey of
my life and understand myself and why I
made these choices and how I can grow
from them when you had to have a drink
starting at 7:00 o'clock in the morning
to go to a school function what kind of
perspective did that give you when you
were able to say whoa I mean I just I
have I'm very conscious in my mind even
if I'm not like speaking it I like I
can't believe that you have to do this
like I was disappointed in myself
but I would still port the drink because
I didn't know how I would make it
through oh I didn't know that I could
actually be strong enough without it and
really I'm with a stronger without it
and I didn't realize I thought that that
was gonna help me through life I didn't
know that it was actually keeping me
from living my life you talk about that
dark Halloween being your rock bottom
when you were at the height of your
substance abuse what were you taking and
how much were you drinking I was it was
really just like diet pills it wasn't it
was something I've been taking for 20
years so I didn't I mean I didn't expect
that it was
a bad thing by any means it was just
something that I always took you know
but I was also I mean that allowed me to
drink more I think than the other people
that would because you had the stimulant
in your system and yeah and then to
sleep at night to sleep at night yes I
mean I have insomnia and I definitely
had to take sleep meds to come down to
come down completely and to try and
sleep for five hours
could you talk about the diet pills so
you're the tender age of 17 years old
when the head of a record label told you
okay great we're signing you now you
need to lose weight
yeah so talk to me a little bit about
that journey and the diet pills and the
body image pressures that you faced for
years
I mean the body image pressures they
never go away because so many people
focus on it I mean people think right
now like oh she snapped back I did not
snap back I wish I just snapped back but
I worked my butt off
you didn't you did to shave you just had
to cheat and ur tummy tucks over the
years yeah and the the tummy tucks were
back to back that was after I had lost a
ton away yeah and I had skin and like
stretch marks because I had to baby back
to back that's right any months apart
and like what I'm being a nine-pounder
almost ten pounder but I still gained so
much weight I just when I get pregnant
I'd blow up same same same we listen to
our bodies that's what we do how will
you help your own daughters not succumb
to those same body image pressures that
you did well I think that we live
in a time right now where women are
really embracing the they're embracing
the everyday woman every shape every
size and that's what we wanted through
our brand the collection that's where we
saw the biggest response you know it's
like thank you for making me feel sexy
at a size 12 yeah I was like I've been a
size 12 yeah you know I wanted to feel
good too I know that actions speak
louder than words but I know there are
mean girls at school you know and I know
I know that my daughter will face those
things but she has confidence already
that is like outstanding so I I'm just
like that is I mean I don't know if it
was because of what I went through as a
child that like took me down because I
was always on stage and like I was
either dressing too seductive which I
wasn't and that's right I help young but
it was always about my look whether it
was you know not covered enough or
covered too much and I love how your
when they go out the door always be kind
sit with the lonely kid you're an
intentional mother and I that's
wonderful we pray for the Mean Girls yes
for them to be shown kindness I need to
jump now to Nick Lachey your dad said
don't marry him you're too young but you
did it do you ever have regrets about
that and also how much of the newlyweds
do you think contributed to the downfall
of that relationship with Nick I was
madly in love I mean I loved everything
about the guy and I wanted to spend the
rest of my life with him I was you know
22 years old when we got married but you
know I thought I knew my future and I
thought he was gonna be in it forever I
thought my dad was completely wrong that
was like no I got this figured out watch
you know like I'll prove you wrong yeah
yeah but like within shooting newlyweds
and within like sudden crazy
I mean we just grew apart in so many
ways and you know we both were at fault
and a lot of things but I mean I'm happy
for him now I mean he's married with
three beautiful children and you know
that was his purpose and he took
heartbreak and made it into something
beautiful and that's what I did as well
but you know it took me longer to get
there but I
he's also eight years older than me so
he was already so grown up when I wasn't
so once I started to you know get covers
and get endorsement deals that were
separate from him because we did
everything together there was a little
bit of tension and like I let a lot less
support and I felt I just felt our
marriage that we really like were kind
of like spinning and trying to tolerate
each other towards the end because we
were so used to being miked up or on the
stage or you know the world took us in
so many ways and they put us as a trophy
couple that we actually weren't I mean
we were at the beginning but it fell out
pretty quick yeah I had to go to the lot
next door to quietly scream at one other
because I'm worried about cameras and
you're not yeah I mean now like it's
like I let people in my house and said
I've been so guarded
yeah about letting anybody take pictures
here or anything like that but since
sobriety I'm like every cop so would you
ever do a Simpson Johnson reality show
oh no I haven't I honestly like after
doing a reality show I have not been
able to watch reality shows yeah because
I know what positions these people hope
becomes art are put in I know when they
go out they're forced to drink I know
like you know if there's so many
different things that I just watch
happening i watch
the destruction of it and for people to
rise above that is a very hard thing
been there done that
can we talk about john mayer for a hot
second I lost track of how many times
you got broken up with what was it about
him he was tormenting you yet you went
back to him what was it about him
John is extremely alluring personality
he wants into a room and he is the room
yeah like you you want to be near him
you want to be around him he just starts
conversations that are so interesting
he's so intelligent and he's an amazing
musician and the songs that he would
write I mean they would bring me back in
his apologies would bring me back in
always so poetic so cool yeah I mean he
made everything sound beautiful so I
thought the next time around like we had
grown and it was gonna be better and
then it would just it was like a cycle
you know that I couldn't even keep was
destructive it was very distracting
Justin Timberlake you two shared a
little kiss after your divorce but then
you kinda left us hanging what happened
next with Justin oh nothing Justin is
like an awesome guy and we truly like
we're just at my house and had a
nostalgic yeah and it was just a funny
moment because and we'd known each other
since we were kids you know yeah it was
a funny moment he took his phone out and
takes Ryan Gosling's like I won and I
was like what are you talking about and
then you were bummed it was a Ryan
Gosling and it was like y'all had a bet
like if I would have known this minute
mm-hmm
things may have been a little different
it might have been the other way
but Justin still like I mean I he's
still a friend like yeah we were to see
each other it's very normal and laugh
about it yeah we laugh you're releasing
new music that actually inspired this
book what do you want people when they
listen to it and absorb it what do you
want them to feel the audiobook is an
amazing experience it was extremely hard
and emotional for me to do I did it in
five days and I didn't realize how
intense it would be when I was reading
everything it was it I mean I like
throughout the audiobook you'll hear me
like I'm very emotional I'd cry and I
have to yeah oh yeah and you'll probably
cry when you mean yeah yeah or it'd be
like wow she's crying over that yeah
like there'll be little things that I'll
cry at that might shock people but the
music is actually everything that
inspired me to get sober and to write
the book because I realized when I was
going down into my studio even though I
was in the comfort of my own house I I
had a drink the pain that I was about to
to go to experience through the lyrics
and through the hilarious because I am a
soulful writer like everything that I
sing I wanted to have the purpose I
wanted to mean something and so I didn't
know where these songs were gonna go
because they were so poetic and deep and
kind of take you to another place and it
would it would it would have been lyrics
that people wouldn't have understood and
I didn't even understand at the time but
once we wrote the memoir and all that
came together I was like I have we
listened to these songs back because I
feel like I had some weird premonition
yeah that things in my life needed to
change and really those songs are my
saving grace
baby that means I'm seeing nothing maybe
I should have seen it coming
the devil on my shoulder
[Music]
there are six songs and I'm not with a
record label anymore so I'm able to give
that to the fans and/or to the reader or
listener I'm able to just give that to
them as you know a part of as a part of
a piece of my journey the way you want
to you're the boss I the way I want to
it like exactly it doesn't have to be
through label and songs don't have to be
chosen that way anybody telling you what
to wear and you know and how to be
because I just know now congratulations
on the book and the sobriety and you've
grown so much through this I know thank
you for sharing it with us
[Music]